this is when we hit 14-hour days full of
production so there's no time to rest
[Music]
don't be shy about your love for all
things frozen we know that you're still
hoping for that frozen 3:00 announcement
and so are we
you also want answers to the questions
that frozen to left hanging well get
ready for all new behind the scenes
secrets thanks to the Disney Plus
docu-series called into the unknown
making frozen - we finally got the
official word on whose voice was calling
Elsa - oughta Holland and Kristen Bell
has revealed how her own real life
struggles had a major influence on on a
story in the second film we also find
out how the origin of one of the new
characters relates to a tragic event in
the directors life discover more secrets
that are uncovered in the docq series
including fun animation reveals plus the
latest plans for the third installment I
would like to formally announce frozen 3
frozen 2 left fans with unanswered
questions that have caused quite a bit
of debate since the movie came out in
November 2019
one of the most ambiguous parts of the
movie was the voice that also heard
calling her you hear it - somebody's
calling us it was never clear whose
voice it was some fans believed it was
her mother Queen I Doudna calling her -
ought to Holland while others thought it
was Elsa's own voice some thought that
it was a spirit and some thought that he
was out to halt in itself and guess what
they weren't the only ones arguing about
it the six-part Disney Plus docu-series
reveals that the voice calling to Elsa
was one of the biggest obstacles for the
filmmakers themselves less than a year
before the release date they were still
debating who the voice belonged to with
us finally making decision about the
voice went back and they actually put a
reprising of the lullaby writer and
co-director Jennifer Lee admitted that
they all had different opinions about it
there were also major struggles with
Elsa song show yourself that tied in to
that uncertainty in the docu-series
Jennifer explains that they show what
they have of the film to a panel every
three months and the panel gives them
brutally honest opinions
Jennifer admitted
pretty intense the feedback we see
responses like I was confused
it wasn't until 11 months before its
release after one of these showings to
Disney Animation's story trust group
that the filmmakers all came to a
unified decision about the voice the
story trust group is a bunch of
creatives from other Disney projects so
they know their stuff and they were
confused about who the voice belonged to
so the filmmakers committed to it being
AI dunas voice and so we all agreed
definitively we're going to answer that
the voice is the mother
Mark Smith the director of story
explains that decision you unifies the
movie in a way by connecting the
flashback of young AI Doudna to the
present-day events and with that
decision it's hard to imagine that the
songs we know a love were ever any
different but they go through rewrites
too just like the script the songwriters
adjusted the tomb so that it had a new
verse solves the song we're so grateful
that you're gonna sing it and they added
and Elsa asking are you the one I've
been looking for they also added the
voices call as well as I do news lullaby
from the opening of the movie and they
got Evan Rachel Wood the voice behind
Queen I Doudna back into the studio to
lay down the vocals that bond is just
unbreakable no matter what happens if
they thought that made it crystal clear
to the audience they were wrong at least
we know now for sure did you get it
right it's not just Elsa we learned more
about in the docu-series
it's also honor or to be more precise
how the voice actor behind on a poured
her own personal struggles into the
character's story yard in September 2018
Kristen Bell told SiriusXM about her
influence on Ana's development in the
second movie there are a lot of very
very intimate moments for me in this
movie that are like she got involved
that during a collaborative writing
process
the actress explained how Jennifer Lee
asked her what she goes through that
similar to the character she voices and
Kristen opened up to Jennifer about a
lot of things that she had personally
been going through and why she thought
that resonated with what honor would be
feeling and so that we we feel the how
hard that is and then even arresting the
song when the audience expects it to go
Jennifer was so inspired
she wrote it into the script but at the
time Kristin couldn't divulge the
details because
were still more than a year away from
the movie's release she explained that
she'd be able to say more when the movie
came out but at the time of that
interview in 2018 she mentioned a
specific songs about particular emotions
and hurdles in her life and what they
taught her it's not just episode two of
this show it's it's something you need
to see them go through in the making
frozen to docu-series Kristen reveals
that honest journey and the song the
next right thing came out about her own
struggles with depression and anxiety
she explains that Ana's mantra of do the
next right thing came out of that
conversation that she had with Jennifer
and it was about her anxiety and
depression
Kristen added that do the next right
thing it really is for anyone who is
feeling low and struggling and does not
know what to do because the only thing
you can do at those lowest moments is
one step at a time
the actress explained that if she wakes
up and is feeling very low she does the
next right thing in a series of small
steps she steps out of bed she brushes
her teeth she has a cup of coffee she
wakes her kids up and she says she takes
those steps and stages when the world
and its problems seemed too big to
handle that will affect me in my bones
forever
the next right thing song is important
on a personal level for the movies
co-director Chris buck - in the
docu-series he reveals how a tragedy in
his life that took place at the end of
creating the first movie relates to the
origin story for one of the new
characters in the second movie the
director of the doc you series Megan
Harding told Collider how they trod
carefully when it came to Chris bucks
personal life she revealed that they
weren't going to go there unless he
wanted to go there and Megan feels lucky
that Chris felt comfortable enough and
was open to share the story of writer in
the docu-series she's talking about the
tragedy that happened towards the end of
production on the first movie
Chris's son Ryder was involved in a road
traffic accident and passed away at just
23 years old that is a huge moment for
me it's very powerful
Megan feels that Ryder's story is very
much a part of how and why frozen - is
the way it is we learn in episode 3 of
the docu series about how frozen -
helped Chris cope with grief he reveals
that
and the rap party was the weirdest thing
for me because all night people were
coming up to him saying how much they
loved the movie and then ten seconds
later they would say how sorry they were
for his loss Chris explains that on a
song in frozen to the next right thing
reminded him to get back up and keep on
he also spoke about the origin of the
character Rider in the second movie
Chris's co-director asked him if it was
ok if they named one of the characters
rider after his son and they gave the
character more to do in the movie
because he's a very light spirit he's a
very positive character who's really fun
and hopeful isn't that a wonderful way
to honor writers memory when we learn
more about the filmmakers personal lives
we get such a deeper insight into the
movies than we ever could just by
watching the film's sure we love finding
out about the behind-the-scenes secrets
to do with how they create the animation
but discovering the true stories behind
the characters which have been inspired
by real-life emotions and experiences is
so fascinating both Chris buck and
Kristen Bell have given frozen fans such
a gift by sharing their personal stories
are you wondering about some of those
Animation secrets Malorie Walters who
animated Elsa revealed how she figured
out how to capture Elsa's movements
during the song into the unknown she
admitted that she'd never animated a
character running before and her
boyfriend came up with a fun idea
Mallory revealed like videotaping me as
I was running animated her based on my
reference and her boyfriend captured it
on camera from his skateboard after we
see her running along our neighborhood
sidewalk she admits I can't believe I
just showed that to you guys
well we're so glad you did Mallory
there's been a lot of frozen news in
June 2020 and it's not just about the
second movie secrets there's also been
chatter about the potential for frozen
three first up there's Josh GAD the
voice behind Olaf has given fans hope
during an interview with pop culture
calm although he admitted that he
doesn't know if and when there will be a
third installment he did reveal that
there's a possibility
going into this film that we wanted it
to age with the viewers who first
experienced this movie in the theaters
we always love it when actors give us a
reason to be optimistic about the future
our favorite franchises if they've been
given the greenlight by the big bosses
to say something like that then we know
it actually is possible
Josh dished about how he teamed up with
Disney to bring at home with Olaf
digital shorts to all of us stuck at
home in recent weeks
he explained that is an example of how
the team behind the movies are keen to
take the opportunity to bring a sense of
hope and inspiration through the
characters whenever the need arises if
ever there was a time when we all need
some hope it's certainly during this
part of 2020 and we can't help but
wonder if this global situation will
influence the filmmakers decision to
bring us frozen 3 after all we've
already seen how the characters have
brought hope and inspiration to fans
around the world in the making frozen to
docu-series animation supervisor wayne
inton shows us a wall of framed letters
that have been sent to the studio
they've proved what a profound impact
frozen has had on so many people
he reads 1 out loud which says my name
is Rachel I'm 15 years old and I believe
I am frozen's biggest fan because the
song let it go literally saved my life
last year Josh described the Olaf shorts
as the frozen saga continuing even if it
wasn't in the form of a third movie yet
he said if there's always a story worth
telling I'm sure that Jennifer Lee and
the incredible team over at Disney
Animation will tell that story one day
of course there's a story worth telling
and that's not all at the end of June
Chris buck spoke with Radio Times calm
about the possibility of another frozen
film in a Facebook live Q&A chris said
that it certainly takes time to consider
how to continue the story we see what
happens at the end but it's all in
support of Elsa story he revealed that
the team was so emotionally and
physically spent after the first movie
that it took them a year before they
even thought about a chapter two they
all needed a break to regroup and think
and we're not surprised given that
they'd spent so many years creating the
film but that doesn't mean that frozen 3
won't happen the director said ask us in
five months given that it takes them
around three years to create the movies
we're looking at quite a wait even if
the three cool gets the green light but
it would definitely
worth the wait which behind-the-scenes
secret did you find the most interesting
and what do you think the chances are of
a third movie in the frozen saga sound
off in the comments below and hit that
subscribe button to be the first to know
when we release more videos on the
things thanks for watching